[Musique]
m
moelleux
c'est une adorable petite rivière qui
court à travers les champs bonjour à toi
tout bonjour les craies de moutons
bonjour très beau papillon ra d'avis si
c'est ton choix
ezoua le fons en grande tenue de
pêcheurs sultan fin tu vas faire fuir
les poissons on accroche un soin stick
ou à l'hameçon oui évidemment alphonse
manque encore un peu d'entraînement
[Musique]
[Rires]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça y'est sa mort non ça ne mord pas sa
belle
c'est un crédit ou tu en as this way
[Musique]
super tonton soit peu du ski nautique
france qui encore mieux du ski nautique
sans eau
[Musique]
revenons à nos moutons je dire à notre
pêche et qu'est ce qu'ils font il ne
faut pas jeter pierres mais ils vont
faire fuir les poissons coucher sales
bêtes
enfin
pourtant on voit avec toutes ces misères
il n'a encore rien pêcher et des normes
en costaud c'est à ce titre on retrouve
dans l'eau ça commence à bien faire
[Musique]
il écoute le petit dostie qu il se porte
on doit ces gens qui ont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voilà nos deux pêcheurs rentrent à la
maison
mouillez hébreu accompagné par un
troupeau de credo gouttes en aragon
petit coup au revoir à tous à tous merci
[Musique]
et
il
nous
on